[Musique]
pour marcher dans la ville et puis jetée
croisés tu m'as dit mademoiselle c'est
trop beau tu es trop de jambes je
voulais pas calculer
et puis je te regarde et je n'ai pas mal
heureusement je suis en bons d'achat
dans ma tête je n'arrive plus à t'oublie
j'sais pas pourquoi je m'entête
juste trop beau à regarder mais qui ok
mais qui valent
une jolie nana mais qui piquent et
médiévale
peut-être que je suis touché
[Musique]
actuellement
je pense qu'à l'amour
[Musique]
mais encore
en fait chevalier j'étais déjà venu à
turin star tu m'as dit j'avoue ta belle
gueule tu fais des vues mais c'est pas
trop mon dell quand tu fais le match où
tu m'as fait pas comme un western
on n'aura plus rien entre nous on peut
faire ça lol
pourquoi je me rappelle me qui inquiète
mais qu'ils valent
[Musique]
une jolie nana qui est piquée mais
qu'ils valent
peut-être que je suis tout môme de 12
ans
[Musique]
tu penses calme
ça plus tôt
bon bon j'suis trop lyon toi tu me cas
l'appa bon j'suis trayons toi tu n'est
qu'à la fin
ah qu'est-ce que c'est trop bon la vie
d'artistes et d'artisans
qu'est ce qu'être bon là les dattiers
je suis en artois
mais toi tu lui
pourtant on kalamu lahya
de reports
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
ciena de négoce de soir